i made a decision right then on i'm
never eating animals seeing what it does
to people
seeing professional athletes being on
plant-based and doing their stuff at the
elite level and i'm an immature if they
can do it at an elite level why can't
why can
i survive being who i am
so me going vegan over five years now
it's five years um
late february so uh belle went
vegetarian the year before we watched
earthlings together
she's bawling her eyes out she said i
can never eat animals so she went
vegetarian
so i grew up in west africa mali where
i've seen people
sacrifice cow sheep and even was part of
holding the legs for it to happen as a
child they make you do that
and you're basically forced into this
culture of meat eating without even
having a choice to and that didn't do
anything to me watching earthlings and
when i went back to look at it i'm like
man i was sick to
to watch this and not change my life i
was even sad
watching it but fast forward to a year
later she wanted me to watch this
documentary called forks over knives
so i said let's just do it i gotta start
listening to her because every time
i listen to do something it ends up
being amazing and uh
we watch it with it why is that i don't
know she's just amazing she's incredible
so 20 minutes into forks overnight i
remember this vividly i looked at her
when my boss dropped she goes are you
okay i said
i don't think i'm okay because i don't
think i could ever eat meat for the rest
of my life but i'm scared i don't know
what to eat
and she said don't worry about it we'll
figure it out so we went vegan together
cold turkey
so i made a decision right then on i'm
never eating animals seeing what it does
to people
seeing professional athletes being on
plant-based and doing their stuff at the
elite level and i'm an immature if they
can do it at a delay level why can't
why can't i survive being who i am and i
eat animal
so i became vegan for selfish reason and
um now it's more than that's more
ethical for me too as well so
it's i'm glad it took that for me to
realize what's happening
in the world even on climate whatever
but the only thing i regret about going
vegan being plant-based is i didn't do
it soon enough
that's the only thing yeah it's
interesting so you were doing it
before the run streak yeah when you were
still
in the professional soccer world yeah i
actually
right when i turn vegan i want to play
in oklahoma city for the oklahoma city
energy they're in the usl
um the lower division just the division
below mls
and i got there i used to get kicked out
of practice i'm not kidding you
i had this energy that my body just
started feeling
and i just couldn't explain it and my
teammate would look at me are you crazy
hello what's going on
with you i remember one game at the
locker room
uh half time one of our teammates goes
if you come in this locker room you
don't feel like you haven't left
everything on a few not exhausted them
and you didn't play
so i humbly raised my hand i said i
disagree with that
because every game i've been giving all
my all but i still feel like i can play
a second game that's how much energy my
body just felt
so just because i don't feel tired
doesn't mean i didn't leave it all out
on the field
and i used to that energy the it was
just people and i
started convincing my teammates to go
plant-based they like had to do this i
just don't eat animal my recovery time
is quicker and things like that and i
can feel it
how how long before you had that
experience it was like making the switch
i switched um a month later i went to
oklahoma to play it was like about a
month later wow yeah
literally switch in february all march
and the first of april i was in oklahoma
so recovery times are better without
running out of energy
not not like petering out in the fourth
quarter or late second half
whatever being young we would be up to
two three in the morning we wake up
everybody's exhausted like i don't know
how we're gonna survive
practice i'm like i feel like i got
enough rest and then when i started
seeing them like why i think it's my
diet it has to be
because i was a big chicken person in
fact i'd have leftover chicken from
night and eat it as breakfast
at morning like eight nine in the
morning which is really they want to
kick you out of practice
yeah my coach my coach would be like hey
hello you're done for the day because
the second team that doesn't play a lot
they practice longer to get more fitness
and game underneath them
okay you had to play he didn't want to
burn you out yeah that's why i got
kicked out of practice
so i would go join them to do extra
practices my coach would
or like a easy day where we don't play
much and i want to stay long and say
hello you're done
you have a game in two days and i want
to stay but i always get kicked out
because i had that energy with me
um i think because of yeah plant-based
do you know this soccer agent called
darren flickcroft heard of him
yeah he's a friend of mine but he's
super plant-based oh wow and
he's a you know he's a big monkey muck
in the soccer agenting
world yeah or whatever but he's like
gung-ho plant-based guy
and a fun fact actually so my neighbor
uh samuel and uh he's girlfriend roberto
grauder who's actually was ranked in
doha for six
for marathon as he was running six in
the world wow so they
saw i kind of started telling them about
the whole vegan
thing so that surprised me with your
book planned power oh cool
yeah so i was literally consuming your
book oh good before the chance continue
yeah i have your book at home so they
give it to me as a gift i don't know it
was for my birthday
last november but it was they say here's
a book i said oh rituals
i didn't know you had that book so super
food so there's a chapter with the
superfoods
so i was just saying okay hello you're
training to run across the country now
yes you're vegan
so now let's add more super foods
because now you want to be you're doing
something that your body foreign so i
need the food
so again thank you for your very well i
mean that out there for all the
plant-based i
was able to contribute some small thing
to this from afar
[Music]
you